well as the government's grappled with
brexit and failed to find a majority for
its plan and Champy's are taking matters
into their own hands tomorrow
MPs could seize control of the brexit
process from the government of one of
the most influential is a chair of the
pranks that Select Committee Hillary ban
who joins us now thank you very much for
being on the program this morning big
week ahead I just want to start off with
some of the speculation in the Sunday
newspapers that there could be a coup
being mounted against the Prime Minister
I mean how do you feel about the
prospect of a new Conservative Party
leader a new prime minister I think
we're probably seeing the final stages
of the current Prime Minister's
leadership but frankly what matters more
is the crisis that is still facing the
country this isn't political crisis of
constitutional crisis economic crisis
and as a result of the decision of the
European Council last week we've gained
an extra two weeks no more
so the real risk of an OD or exit has
merely been delayed it has not been
averted so we need to take things in
order the first priority is ensure that
there is not a no deal breaks if the
Chancellor couldn't have been clearer in
his interview with you earlier when he
talked about it being catastrophic for
the British economy on that I agree with
him completely and the second thing we
have to do is for Parliament and that's
the purpose of the amendment that a
cross-party group of MPs have put down
for Monday is to see whether there is an
alternative approach which can command
support but I've also come to the
conclusion that thirdly whatever deal
Parliament is prepared to put forward
should go back to the British people and
given the crisis that were in at the
same time that might make it more
difficult for other parliamentarians to
support what are whatever it is you're
calling Volcker for many people the
thought of a second referendum is
something that fills in with dread
because it means what they would say is
overturning the result of the first one
well I've reflected long and hard on
this and I've been very struck in the
last few weeks the Prime Minister
brought her deal to Parliament it was
rejected she brought it back and it was
rejected she may bring it back this week
and I suspect it will be rejected again
now we're told that
that is democratic in an attempt to try
and get us as MPs to change our mind
someone please explain to me why it is
undemocratic to ask the British people
whether on reflection they would like to
change their mind or not the point about
a confirmatory referendum and the
amendment that Peter Carlin Phil Wilson
have put together is I think the way
forward Jeremy spoke very movingly when
he was on your program I think last week
it says look we've prepared whatever
deal Parliament can agree with the
European Union put that to the people if
that's carried then we leave on that
basis so if people want to vote leave
again of course they can do so we now
know a bit more about what breaks it
means we don't yet know the full story
but if that is rejected then the
alternative would be that we would be
remain in the European Union and I if
Parliament remains deadlocked and
there's no guarantee that the indicative
vote process that the selectivity I
chair called for which I hope will take
place next week no guarantee it will
resolve the deadlock in Parliament and
in those circumstances other way is of
getting a final decision other than to
go back to the British so what do you
vote for the Prime Minister's deal as it
stands if it was then put to a public
vote well I think that she would I think
the proposal is in effect Parliament
would allow it to go through what that
only it well people could have a stain
but the fact is it would be approved but
only if the prime minister in the
government gave an absolutely category
that it would then be put to the British
people because you can only put in a
referendum a second referendum a leave
proposition that has been negotiated
with the European Union that's the only
one that there is at the moment we may
negotiate a different one Norway in a
customs union for example which there
may be a lot of support for but in the
end I think you need people's consent
because we're now nearly three years on
and the truth about the last or two or
three quarter years is that the
fantasies that were presented by the
leave campaigners during the referendum
and you've heard them on the program
this morning have collided with the
reality
it's a national crisis because the
government has failed to face up to the
wheel services rather than carrying on
pretending we can have our cake and eat
it because we can't and now we know that
now you more than perhaps anyone a very
very plugged into what's happening with
these votes next week you've been
talking to mums the government bad as
well can you just explain what you ik
what you believe the strategy will be
next week help will unfold will there be
a free vote will the government be
effectively allowing the amendment
through what's happening well it's not
entirely clear what the government's
approach is going to take and I listen
very carefully to what Philip Hammond
had to say because the government could
have taken control of this process but
we are acting as backbenchers because
the government has failed to do that
it's in complete and utter chaos we can
all see that and I think the key
alternative options are do you want a
free trade agreement like Canada now I
will not vote for that because it
doesn't solve the problem of the border
in Northern Ireland it doesn't give you
the kind of friction free trade which
Adam Marshalls members need in order to
carry on with their businesses the
second option is a customs union I think
that is an essential building block of
solving the Northern Ireland border
problem the third is a Norway plus
arrangement customs union plus small way
it seems to me that is essential if
you're going to keep an open border
honor the Good Friday Agreement and
ensure that British continue to trade
freely and then those are policy choices
about the future and then separate from
that is how does the final decision get
made and that's where a confirmatory
referendum comes in and I vote for that
when it is presented to Parliament I
think we could look it's very
complicated isn't talked about all these
different way forwards but I think we
have got a graphic where these are
what's going into expect him effectively
as some of the things to be Philip
Hammond basically ruled up the top one
No Deal Bret sir and he ruled out the
bottom warrant revoke the article 50 but
he didn't rule out any of the others I
mean is that effectively where you are I
mean I guess the top three and you
probably wouldn't vote for but are you
willing to stomach the others well a no
deal-breaker it's been rejected by
Parliament twice now and that's
absolutely clear and there's another
amendment down for Monday from my
colleague Yvette Cooper which is looking
ahead because we must ensure going back
to my first point that we do not leave
to deal a free trade agreement doesn't
work indeed the Prime Minister made that
clear she said a Canada deal wouldn't
work for the Northern Ireland problem
the PM Steel's been rejected twice now
and I think whether you can describe a
customs union plus the PM's deal the
customs union would be different we've
been asking the Prime Minister to accept
the basic building block of making
progresses a customs union and she is
resolutely refused to do that I think a
customs union and single market or
variation they're off I support a
confirmatory referendum the replication
of article 50 I think the only
circumstances it comes right back to the
first point on your list if we got to
what three weeks time and then you said
I'm sorry we're not prepared to give you
an extension now I'm absolutely clear
that number one priority is to avoid a
No Deal brexit if they refuse to give
them some steps and then Parliament
would be faced with a choice about
whether to use that particular method
but we've got to do our job and it's the
government's failure to do its job is
why Parliament people say grab control
of the order paper
this is MPs doing their job as the
public would expect us to do to try and
find an alternative way forward well
let's talk about that about MPs
effectively doing its job as you would
say taking control of the order pay for
his office word I was in Brussels this
week and I spoke to Philippe LAN bear
who's an MEP on the BRICS that steering
group and I can have a quick look at
what he told me the delay was all about
he said what we did here is to create
some space to let Parliament take hold
of the process he described it as to
give another chance to the adults in
Westminster I mean is that what's
happening is this effectively a
parliamentary coup it's not a coup
because in the in Parliament has to
agree a deal in a way forward that's
what we're elected to do that's what the
public expect us to do now I very much
welcome the fact that the EU agreed to
provide some more time because they're
no deal breaks it would be catastrophic
for us for the Republic of Ireland it'd
be very damaging for the European Union
I don't think they want to see that
happen but they are as frustrated as
everybody else at the government's
fracturing its inability to move and the
really central question for next week
Sophie is supposing Parliament did say
we're in favor of a different
all the indications are from the last
two 3/4 years is that the Prime Minister
has refused to shift an inch she keeps
saying well let's talk my deal or no
deal my deal on it because we haven't
got much time now and and
david Livington a man that you've spent
a lot of time with in meetings in recent
months the de facto Deputy Prime
Minister a man who some people are
saying should be put in place as a
caretaker Prime Minister would you
welcome that look the leadership of the
Conservative Party is a problem for the
Conservative Party I would like to see
it is a problem as well I think it's the
angels government but what I think is
essential now is whoever is the leader
of the Conservative Party if Parliament
decides that it is prepared to support a
way forward and if Parliament decides
that it then wants to put that to the
British people in a confirmatory
referendum then the nation needs
leadership that is prepared to
compromise that's the crucial point and
the reason to resume is in such
difficulty this morning is she had
steadfastly refused to shift an engine
is no good saying my door is open come
and talk to me if her mind is closed and
I'm afraid that's what the last two and
three-quarter years have demonstrated
plus there's been an unwillingness to
tell the British people the truth about
the real choices we face okay we're at
the time Harry ban thank you very much